so we're on our way to the accident and
we're almost there I think there's just
a few parts of my way that we still have
to do basically as a short introduction
we're going to be estimating at the
planet ocean media there's going to be a
lot of people over there not just from
the Netherlands but from all over the
world and we're basically just going to
invite all the rights and call a lot of
other people just do a bit of media
thing and see how it's going to go and I
thought I would block this as just a
quick test to see how as we go
and actually get a bit of a sense Blanco
particularly really awesome it's really
close and really cozy and we're just
going to have a fun day and I'm going to
book it so yeah I'll see you guys in the
park I think we're getting pretty close
now actually I think I already see the
see the red power of the hotel right
there yeah there you go that's hotel oh
yeah
Roma's dead and it's raining which is
the best weather Dutchman
so one of the first things that really
shocked me about the market is the fact
that it actually looks really good when
I when I came here in the winter and
there were no trees and anything it
actually looked very bare but now it's
all of the tree fall I guess you'd be
the judge
it actually looks really amazing and
here's the wild Rudy eating another
waffle I think that's your third waffle
this morning at the time I'm online I'm
eating one that's color that's got to be
a great first actually you haven't added
Dutch so powerful yet so whatever yeah
you're going to have to get one of those
they're amazing but yeah we're totally
going to go for some really good food
today there's also the pancake house
over here which I don't know if I've
been here but this pancake house it has
some of the best actually watch right
inside the respond there I wanna see a
little so that's I'm after years 15
years ago I probably I ever vote I don't
know
all good enough for now we're going to
try a Flying Dutchman oh yeah we're
going to try Flying Dutchman and see how
to code
there's actually a queue for 150 minutes
for symbolic us so we're going to skip
that all right so we've got to change
the plan we're actually going to go to
Baron 1898 first and it's only go 15
minutes that's quite good to the start
of the day and look at that it is really
one of the best looking right in the
entire country ultimately in Europe
hopefully in the world just just a look
at that drop alone right there with all
of the support underneath it it's
beautiful
so I've just come out of Baron 1898 it's
looking really amazing in the background
right there still no car going from it
but it's been really fun lots of people
who've done it for the first time as
always its bit of a short ride roller
coaster wise but in terms of scenery
complete experience is really one of my
favorites and I will go into my favorite
ultra part the Flying Dutchman
so what did you think of Baron 18 I did
I like a experience of the groceries
best part for me like to summarize like
a better culture but the seeming the
music shows that that's what I know
yeah well now we're here and they're
getting more the feeling is great but
this one right
yeah Baron like the flying dutchman is
my favorite ride at the park because the
theming is very immersive the queue the
station the exterior even all of the
buildings around here is there any one
for an hour it's beautiful and they sit
eating here shows how they eat you it is
amazing
yeah it's amazing so we're going to try
flying dutchman right now and see how it
goes
lots of people trying it for the first
time
right
Yuda you sexy [ __ ]
beautiful for coma art when you
especially smell the sound of the little
pleasing I love the smell of proper
model basically we have to write this
right now we've tried to go on choice in
the Dragons but yeah we have some
technical difficulties while we were
spending in the fear so we're trying to
inset now Flying Dutchman was amazing
though right it was what we had back at
Pacific or whatever it was so good right
and that's where the pepper and he likes
to go to not food but it was pretty good
[Music]
don't you
so which one are you going to take my
good toys death
okay
is going to love coin that's going down
it should be it yeah and now you should
be able to open one there we go and they
have it Oh a product yeah it's really
hot
don't bite into it yet you should wait
well cool down a little bit
[Music]
we won
Oh God smells logging yeah
[Music]
[Music]
ah
Oh
to
all right so Joey and I are currently
smoke at the same time so it's a little
bit difficult right now we're in a
Milwaukee house right now in the in the
wall that'll be lively and now we're in
the laughing house right now which is
really interesting circuit and if you
walk over it every every single parsec
is going to make a beer
[Music]
Oh
Oh
and RMI doing like no you have to hold
it move a bit to the left you're George
you're right I mean yes yes wait wait no
no I have to move back a little bit like
idiots
[Music]
[Music]
oh there's weird
[Music]
so cool
yes
you
[Music]
Oh
though
[Music]
like I left my spare batteries or broken
so we basically go check it out super
wide we've got a big gang over here
going bollocky for one last time is it's
like wonderful scent or something like
second paper again so a pretty big line
oh I'm so minute oh okay oh and we're
still recording I'm gonna have to end it
right here because it's almost broke and
I don't know how long it's gonna do
procedure I don't know for how long it's
going to keep up but it's been awesome
it's been an awesome day sorry I haven't
done so much the entire day I just have
battery problems
hopefully we'll fix that next time but
yeah and also a little bit of a trip
reports April share all of the different
folks you can probably tell my voice is
a little bit dead by now but it's been
awesome so thank you guys and I'll leave
this video with a short montage of all
sorts of
[Music]